all right back to our breaking news now
from Sweden where the prosecution
Authority says it will not proceed with
its rape investigation into WikiLeaks
founder Julian Assange let's speak to
our correspondent Nadine barber he's
following this from London so what of
the prosecutors been saying Nadeem about
why they're dropping this case
essentially well the decision has been
announced by the Deputy Director of
Public Prosecution ever Murray person in
Sweden the basic reason is the quote
evident that evidence has weakened
considerably due to the long period of
time that has elapsed since the events
in question now in a press release the
Deputy Director of Public Prosecutions
there reminds people that the initial
investigation including allegations of
rape started in 2010 so 9 years ago then
they remind people that once Julian
Assange had effectively gone into hiding
in the Ecuadorian embassy here in London
after breaching his bail conditions
while he was being sought by the Swedish
authorities they failed to actually get
him to go to Sweden although it's true
that he was interviewed by Swedish
officials in the Ecuadorian Embassy so
the the case the investigation was
effectively dropped but then when he was
forced out of the embassy earlier this
year and arrested by British police the
investigation was reopened at the
request of the complainant but now the
Swedish justice system evidently saying
that too much time has elapsed and that
the evidence in their eyes has weakened
too far there's no prospect of a trial
really so so that's their reasoning and
now they never had any reaction from
Sandra's team we have I just should
point out that all along he has rejected
all of the allegations which were never
actually put brought to charges in
Sweden
but now the editor-in-chief of the
WikiLeaks website which julian assange
helped to found has welcomed this
announcement saying let us now focus on
the threat mr. Assange has been warning
about for years
the belligerent prosecution of the
United States and the threat it poses to
the First Amendment so the background so
that is that Julian Assange is now in
Belmarsh prison here in London while the
British government considers a request
from the US for his extradition he faces
allegations of conspiring to break into
a classified computer belonging to the
Pentagon and if convicted he could be
jailed for up to a hundred and seventy
five years on those charges now all
along Julian Assange has said that his
ultimate fear is being extradited to the
US where he says he could possibly face
the death penalty but there but he has
in some circles at least a received
assurances that that would not be the
case still his legal team say that he
must not be sent they are saying he
should be treated as a journalist and
that the case raises serious questions
for the freedom of the press his lawyer
just a few days ago said his health is
significantly deteriorating in prison
the Australian government has said that
it just definitely won't be stepping in
to help and that he should be treated as
any other citizen and citizens and
critics of Mr Assange say much the same
thing that he knew what he was doing and
that he was not acting as any other
journalist would have done when he
released a whole dump of information
without any kind of sifting through it
big questions in terms of justice but
what the the case doesn't really change
in light of what the Swedish prosecutors
have said in the last couple of hours
no theme thank you for that for now that
is nothing bother with all the latest
again on that breaking news Sweden's
prosecution authorities saying they will
not proceed would the rape investigation
into Julian Assange thank you the team